muslim country but even in these
countries these islamic countries
that are throwing acid in the face she
suffered third degree burns when her
ex-boyfriend hired another man to throw
acid in her face these people that
practice the islamic religion open the
door as you would normally
and one motion bang this is for you mate
it's a guy called yes and that's those
are the words david phillips which we'll
get on to him in just a moment these
islamic countries
the attack happened in daylight in
downtown vancouver washington
keeping it real real sally keep it get
ready for eddie we encourage people to
come to us
and ass
assalamu alaikum greetings of peace how
are you guys doing welcome to the dean
show my special guest mustapha
omar how are you doing i'm doing great
you've heard of our friend joe hogan
rogan rogan yes i have there's so many
people that have been killed by drones
that were absolutely innocent a lot of
them children a lot of them women a lot
of them completely you know civilians
yeah some of uh
he's pretty um well known also in the
jiu jitsu community you know i do jiu
jitsu some of my students have brought
to my attention uh some of his episodes
he's had some great guests
they talk about nutrition and talk about
sports they talk about you know
different random topics
but the the topics
that he's talked about are a variety of
different ones but but one that really
caught my interest and usually it's not
just him when people start talking about
the thing that's most precious to me and
yourself and over how many 1.7 billion
muslims when they talk about islam yeah
it really touches my heart
but
it also kind of throws you off when they
start talking they don't check their
facts
and they have and i've noticed you had
some people some supposed experts on
islam
you know candidly just freely openly
speaking about it when you go back and
fact check and that's one thing that
people appreciate about joe
is that he has the person in the back
end kind of checking the facts but
here's the thing you know even when you
do go back uh it's interesting that and
i believe it was in april of um
1979 something like that time magazine
did an article
discussing the amount it was like over a
span of 100 years
over 60 000 publications books were
written against islam right so that's
the other thing when you go back and you
start you know fact checking are you
really actually checking the facts
because you're you're gonna the
islamophobia industry is so huge it's a
200 plus million dollar industry
so i hope after this joe
he can invite someone like you you're in
california i'm in southern california
yes yeah that would be i think that
would be great you know that would be um
being genuine you know because you got
all these people coming on you know when
you talk about uh islam and these are
obviously islamophobes right yeah what
do you what what are your thoughts on
that yeah i mean someone who really
hates islam they have an irrational fear
of islam which is what islamophobia is
right they're going to give you a very
distorted view of what the religion
represents so it's it's if someone is
trying to be honest they're trying to be
objective they like to do fact checking
then they should make sure they bring a
person who actually can at least
represent what the muslim viewpoint is
and then weigh it and then do your fact
checking and then decide between you
know what is fact and what is fiction
that's exactly what needs to be done
rogan i mean we have a
a lot of things i think he's a pretty
cool guy you know i think that you know
he does jiu jitsu he's into health he's
into eating real food we talk about
those things
and i and i would paint to an individual
like it's matt you you've also trained a
little bit uh jiu jitsu right yes you
know for someone from the outside who
doesn't know jiu jitsu right they can't
really appreciate the technical aspect
of it just like someone
uh you know coming on talking about uh
brazilian gracie jiu jitsu and they're
like look at these guys you know karate
guy or someone who's you know because
it's not bad for bad for business taking
over right it's the proven most
effective martial art and they're like
well what they do is you know they get
these guys between their legs you know
and they try to get them tap out by
having by squeezing them so hard between
their legs that their guts come out or
you know they put the arm lock on and
they get their their their um buttocks
so close so they like the the toxic air
out of their rear come up you know just
i'm just ridiculous things but they can
make up stuff like this that's an
analysis
they're commenting but these guys you
know have no joe who's an expert ufc
commentator right now someone comes on
who's who doesn't know the sport or he's
and now let's say this guy's a a golfer
right he's commentating you know he's
coming on he has no clue what's going on
in the ground
you can appreciate that now you're
talking about islam right and bringing
on these
excuse my lane with bozos yeah they
don't know
um
what really islam you're an islamic
scholar
and this term is let's start with that
islamophobia joe even said i'm sad he
says i'm islamophobe i am islamophobic
said it yeah that's that's very
unfortunate i saw that clip and uh
you know this idea of he doesn't realize
what islamophobia is or what it is in
fairness he also said he was christian
uh uh
yeah yeah so i mean the context in which
he was trying to say it is that look i
criticize all religions i don't like
other religions and i should have the
right to criticize all of them and yeah
from that perspective he's got a point
yes he can criticize other religions
sure he can criticize islam but there's
two things you should keep in mind when
you're criticizing islam you want to
number one at least be respectful right
you don't have to put everyone else down
when you're criticizing them right
that's that's intellectual integrity and
then the second aspect is when you're
criticizing criticize correctly
criticize with actual facts right there
are things you don't agree with
you don't have to agree with everything
you don't have to you don't have to
accept islam but when you're criticizing
don't criticize false things right and
this is the problem with with some of
these guests that he's been bringing on
and some of the comments that you know
joe was making is that he's saying false
things about islam attributing them to
islam but they have nothing to do with
islam totally false now totally false i
mean this is that's misleading then
that's it's extremely misleading and not
only is it misleading it's not only
intellectually misleading it actually
causes violence
islamophobia results in people it
results in mosques being burned around
the country
people being shot in a mosque in canada
just a few months ago it results in
people dying
from mosques being burned down to people
being attacked for just looking like
they might be muslim the alleged case
here where an indian man was killed in
kansas we saw an 87.5 percent increase
in hate crimes against muslims well
those are official numbers from experts
who study this day in day out that's not
to say president trump is necessarily
responsible so there appears to be a
correlation we don't know if it's a
cause yet but there appears to be a
correlation
between political rhetoric
and hate crime but it raises the
question could trump do more to help
stop it all here's what history tells us
following the 9 11 attacks
hate crimes spiked six days after those
attacks though president george bush
spoke at the islamic center of d.c
speaking of tolerance and hate crimes
dropped 66
in the next six days it results in
people
failing to get jobs uh because people
are discriminating against muslims i
mean this is this is happening this is a
reality that's taking place and joe is
feeding into you know putting more fuel
on that fire basically he's feeding into
that propaganda machine that's taking
place right now against muslims
particularly in the west and that's
something that he should be more careful
about yeah where do you want to start
there's a there's a few here there there
was a lot he's over over the years he's
brought on many people
so maybe we can do a continuation but i
i think let's start with islamophobia i
mean
one of the guys he brought on he comes
up with this ridiculous idea that
islamophobia
you know
it was invented by the muslim
brotherhood right right yeah and
actually the term started as
you may or may not know it started with
the muslim brotherhood
a very smart strategy
and it's just this term so that no one's
allowed to criticize islam and that's
not the point you go to any university
you know in in america and there's
articles critics you know criticizing
islam or whatever it is right but it's
done in a respectful academic manner
it's not done in a hostile manner
there's a difference between that this
idea of islamophobia being invented by
the muslim brotherhood first of all so
what if it was but but what they're
trying to say is that you know we should
be scared of them we should we should
have this fear of what's going on this
is a complete you know this is a hoax
basically someone came up with this
random idea islamophobia is a term
that's been used for a hundred years
it one of its earliest appearances was
used in a book written about the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him in french so
in 1918 they were using the term
islamophobia in french
throughout the 20s throughout the 30s i
started to become more prevalent in the
70s and the 80s and specifically after
september 11th and with you know rising
islamophobia that came out this is so
basic fact checking that he could have
gone he could have gone to and i'm not
even advertised website robert spencer
is a guy who hates muslims to the core
he's like
ma like the king of islamaphobes
basically this guy had to come up with
an article saying look guys we shouldn't
make this argument because it has
absolutely no basis whatsoever so if
there was fact checking going on and i
hope you know he goes back and double
checks this this is just a false theory
so we shouldn't just keep throwing out
all these red herrings which are which
are false just to distract people you
know away from the topic yeah and that's
not that's not being uh in
intellectually uh uh approaching uh the
topic and it's not being genuine and i
think i think joel i mean i hope that
this you know gets to him and we know
some of the same people also and
and i hope that uh he can he can take a
turn towards the better and be more
genuine in covering this because it's
something that that does like you said
affect the lives of so many people so
many people have because of islamophobia
the hate machine mosques are being
burned down people are being killed
leaders in the chicago area demand a
hate crime investigation after three
muslim students were killed in north
carolina this week the students were
shot in the head tuesday at their
apartment complex a very disturbing note
filled with hate was found next to her
at 11 15 in the morning the teen walks
into the family's skyview street home to
find two things
evidence of some kind of break-in in the
rear of the home
and her mother in a pool of blood on the
dining room floor next to her mother she
says is a hateful note to the effect of
go back to your native country several
u.s cities investigations are underway
into possible hate crimes against
muslims demarco morgan is following this
surveillance video shows a suspect
punching kicking and stomping on a
muslim teenager in brooklyn new york the
beating took place outside a mosque
during a midnight prayer service graphic
pictures show how badly the teen and his
friend were beaten the mosque is urging
police to investigate the attack as a
hate crime one of the victims says the
attacker called him a terrorist as he
kicked him in minneapolis police are
also investigating the recent shooting
of two muslim men as a possible hate
crime this weekend authorities in
florida arrested 25 year old taylor
anthony mazzanti in connection with the
beating of a man outside the same mosque
orlando nightclub shooter omar mateen
again
you know it's women's hijabs are being
ripped off i mean violence is escalating
and i'm sure he doesn't want to be uh
contributing to that absolutely yeah
let's go on to the fgm the final gen he
talks about you know the female genital
mutilation female genital mutilation
yeah he talked to ian hersey ali about
it and she gets labeled in islamophobe
because she talks openly about the
problems with the ideology and she's a
woman who experience female genital
mutilation i mean she was that was she
had to flee her country and now she's
here writing books and giving lectures
and the the hardcore left the far left
crazies are attacking her as being
islamophobic yeah and honor killings
honor killing is a real thing yeah i
mean this is not this is not like an
imaginary idea that's never enforced
it's a real thing yeah yeah so he makes
his comment he throws in a bunch of
stuff and he's like you know oh well
these muslims they do female genital
mutilation and there's honor killings
and women can't drive and just throws
out a bunch of stuff and and none of
this stuff is associated with islam so
let's let's break it down real quick um
let's talk about women not being able to
drive okay women aren't even allowed to
drive right i mean they have to have a
male companion when they go out at night
i mean there's there's some unbelievably
regressive ideas that are just accepted
because we don't want to appear to be
homophobic or excuse me islamophobia
this happens in one place
one country and that's saudi arabia
saudi arabia's population in terms of
muslims there's 1.7 billion muslims in
the world what is saudi arabia's
population relative to 1.7 billion it's
like less than two percent it's like
almost in negligible right when did
women uh get banned from driving in
saudi arabia like you know when uh you
know like 60 years ago 100 years ago
since the time of the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him until the 1900s before
the saudi regime came in women were
riding camels and horses whatever
driving was at that time right so number
one you don't judge the entire muslim
population and say this is some kind of
something to do with islam that women
are not allowed to drive
number two this is something that they
were they were driving quote unquote
whatever they were driving at the time
camels horses you know uh they were
driving for 1300 years
so this is a saudi thing it is an a
saudi arabian cultural thing number
three if you ask the muslim scholars in
saudi arabia
do you you know is is this ban on women
driving is it islamic or is it cultural
the scholars in saudi arabia will tell
you the muslim scholars will tell you no
it's nothing to do with islam it's a
cultural ban this is part of our culture
this is what we do we practice this
they're they're not even claiming it's
islamic yet you keep getting this
accusation again and again and it's it's
almost we keep on hearing it oftentimes
people keep quoting well well women in
islam can't drive no women in saudi
arabia aren't allowed to drive there are
49 muslim majority countries that's one
the other 48 don't have any problem with
women driving so that's that's a
non-topic that should not be affiliated
with islam in any way shape or form so
it's not affiliated with islam i i try
to investigate what's the the wisdom
behind it you know is it again not to do
islam but what did they say you know is
it something because what do they even
culturally because even when someone uh
looks into it and sees like uh again not
to do with islam but culturally why are
they is this is why are they doing it
you know why did they prohibit i heard
something along the line because when
you go through in some places where you
know if a woman to protect her from
when she goes out somewhere in in a
rural area in the desert you know there
was uh highway robbers yeah something
like a production yeah some kind of
protection that's probably some type of
rationale
yeah but like as an american right this
doesn't concern me so much i mean this
is saudi culture yeah this is an
internal issue i let them deal with it
yeah why should i be sitting here and
why should joe be sitting here there's
so many issues in the world that we can
focus on you know you know you know in
india we had some guests from india they
said look if you eat a hamburger you go
to jail for seven years why are you
talking about that exactly that should
make headline news right a hamburger if
you eat meat because they worshipped the
cow i couldn't believe it yeah did you
hear about this did you know that i know
i didn't hear about it yeah
yeah uh i mean women are being killed in
india
young girls are being buried alive i
mean they're being killed in china the
same thing has happened there's so many
issues
to to bring up but then we go and focus
on oh well look saudi arabia is is doing
this we need to liberate the woman over
there
end somehow it's associated with islam
so first of all it's not association
it's not associated with islam not
associated let's go to the next one you
want to add more something else no
that's good honor killings honor killing
so this idea just keeps being thrown out
there oh we have honor killings
honor killing honor killings it's very
clear in the quran you cannot take the
life that god has prohibited you to take
life is honored right except with some
right right unless you're impo you know
you're enforcing some type of law
someone stole or committed murder or did
some type of major crime or something
like that no one is allowed to take the
life of another person now is honor like
in this honor killing idea is basically
you know you've um your daughter or your
son goes and does something that you
didn't want them to do and you end up
killing them right or you end up killing
someone else and this tribe gets in a
fight with another tribe
where is this in islam i would love to
see one verse in the quran quoted
regarding this practice not there's not
a single verse in the quran i would love
to see one hadith one statement of the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him where
this practice is somehow justified or
something it's not in fact islam forbade
all of these type of killings right and
actually put an end to it this this is a
tribal practice right this idea of
exaggerated honor and my honor has been
there's no basis whatsoever so whenever
you ask someone about honor killings say
okay show me some evidence and what
they're gonna do is like well look there
was a one muslim a guy who was in this
one country in this one village and he
happened to do it right so there you
there you go one guy out of 1.7 billion
people or 100 or a thousand people out
of 1.7 billion people some house you
know makes a justification that the
religion is teaching them to do that
we don't do that in america we don't go
oh look there's a bunch of people that
went and shot their family they shot
their parents or their parents went and
shot their kids 25 year old brian
lawrence pleaded guilty to murder
charges after admitting to police he
beat and burned her body before dumping
her remains in the water
lawrence told investigators he was
jealous of all the attention maddox
received mccarthy is charged with
murdering the three-year-old girl the
world came to know as baby doe her
mother is charged with being an
accessory prosecutors say bella was
murdered because mccarthy believed she
was possessed by the devil the true
story this isn't something you made up
uh you took a lie detector test yes i
did and you're the one who insisted on
taking it
you passed it
telling the truth as far as you sleeping
with your father he says her
ex-boyfriend bit off her nose the
accused ex-boyfriend chris campbell flew
into a violent rage when michelle told
him their relationship was over after
eight months of dating even a bar code
like an item in a grocery store
fbi is telling us agents have rescued
more than 100 children from sex
trafficking rings in cities across the
country sexual slavery here at home
how does it still happen and here in
america the business of sexual slavery
is booming you don't say oh well that's
because they're american or that's
because they're christian or that's
because they're secular or because they
were liberal or because they were
conservative we don't make these kind of
you know conclusions but when it comes
to islam the rules somehow seem to be
changing and it's like oh we're going to
make these conclusions by what some of
these crazy people or these bad apples
have been doing we're going to go and
blame the entire religion and that's
disingenuous very disingenuous very and
they they bring up uh
acid in the face muslin country but even
in these countries this is these islamic
countries
christie sims slipped into a coma two
months later she awakened and this is
what she looked like against these
radical
fundamentalist people that are throwing
acid in the face
the attack happened in daylight in
downtown vancouver washington bethany's
mother describes the horrific incident a
woman approached her and said hey pretty
girl and she turned around
and
she asked if she wanted something to
drink and my daughter said no the
attacker splattered acid directly into
bethany's face this lady before we start
yeah you say you'd known her for ten
years yeah so you'd grown up with her
yeah we're friends since you were like
about 11 12 yeah 21 year old angelime
from pinon cambodia was not having it
when her fiance 23 year old length
ochiata broke up with her she decided it
would be a good idea to try and pour
acid on him while riding on the back of
his motorcycle these things are horrible
right that if islam was implemented the
the sharia or the law and you did
something like this don't acid or you do
you bring harm to a human human being
like this you know in this way
i mean what would happen yeah i mean
this is really it's it's taking
advantage of people's ignorance of islam
exactly most people don't know a thing
about islam and they're like okay you
know let me inform you what islam is
instead of telling them oh muslims
believe in one god and they play they
pray five times a day and they give
charity and they fast in the month of
ramadan let me just teach you these
things which are some cultural practice
that i found somewhere and let me
attribute them to islam somehow so that
you become afraid of islam
and that's where islamophobia comes from
this irrational false fear of islam it
says my good friend gives us analogies
as if martians came down to the u.s and
they wanted to know about america
and all we told them about was the
electric chair the penal system right
the electric chair you know the firing
squad
and all the other executions that are
out there and and we didn't tell them
all about all the other beautiful things
well there's what what 6236 uh ayahs
verses in the quran how much does the
penal code i mean to run any society and
he said there's got to be laws in place
and what is it one percent or two
percent very small
yeah that's uh that's cherry picking
cherry picking yeah yeah that's the
problem yeah so we got fgm fgm honor
killing nothing to do there is no honor
in taking and it's like you cannot
there's
there's no honor killings there is no
honor killing so joe right there and his
guests and whoever brought this he was
affected he's been he's a victim like
many have but do you want to stay a
victim there's two ways to be fooled as
the saying goes to believe something
that's not true or to continue believing
something to refuse to believe something
that is true so we're bringing joe the
facts all right so he can turn away or
if he's genuine he can really
i think have you on we had someone in
that area all right why not he's done
over almost a thousand pot close to a
thousand podcasts why not bring that one
he had all these islamophobes right
right right talking misinformation lies
about islam why not have a muslim and
that's to go hopefully at the end of the
show we can have you guys push this to
him and hopefully i'll get to him and
and he can go ahead and make an
adjustment there and make things right
because that's offending over 1.7
million it's not about people say oh
it's free speech
just freedom of speech
you know what what do you say today i
mean this idea
it's hate speech right and we we you
know we have this conception when it
comes to race we don't start using the
n-word we don't start you know making
fun of you know jews and their race and
all of that stuff there is a certain
type of speech where we should at least
show some level of respect right and so
this idea of hate speech which not only
is you're free to talk you know mention
your ideas but the way in which you
mention them in terms of how much
implication will there be how much
violence will be caused how much
problems will result by the way you're
speaking that that's just something that
should be taken into consideration and
it is taken into consideration you can't
you know yell fire in a crowded theater
and not be punished for it so there are
there are certain restrictions on this
idea of free speech that every society
has to have in order to maintain some
level of control freedom of speech is a
good thing you want to air your views
about islam okay go ahead you know air
your views but at least do it with
proper fact checking yeah do it in the
right way and and and try to be
respectful about it you're more likely
to convince other people than to just
throw out your your hatred and your
anger
and the best way to fact check also
because i mentioned you know i have so
much negative propaganda so you might
fall into one of these sites that are
just professional islam ambassadors they
get paid for is again to have
a muslim scholar someone such as
yourself uh if you want someone else or
whoever we can have our brother here or
we can hook you up joe and we can bring
someone an expert in this area to help
clear up many of these misconceptions
fgm fgm female genital mutilation so
this idea of female genital mutilation
um most people have probably heard about
this it's cutting part of the women's
private parts out or or the entire thing
or closing it or something like that
basically this practice began either in
sudan or egypt
800 bce 800 years before the birth of
jesus right what does that say off the
bat
this is not something that islam
introduced it's not something that you
know all of a sudden islam which came
600 years about 600 years after jesus or
the quran somehow introduced into this
region now where is this taking place
primarily it takes place in africa
northeast africa and kind of spread
across africa this is an african issue
so christians are doing it there
christians are doing it there let me
give you some statistics here you got uh
eritrea
christian country majority christian you
got ethiopia christian country majority
you know christian population and the
rates of fgm in these countries are 90
percent and 75 percent i mean that
christians are doing it you look at the
country of niger niger is an interesting
case 55 of christians in niger are
practicing fgm
two percent of muslims are practicing
fgm so what's going on here the
christians are doing and the muslims are
not doing it so what happened all of a
sudden something flipped around you look
in eritrea you're looking at level three
fgm which is uh infibulation which is
the worst type right
it's tribal
one tribe will do it and the other tribe
will not do it you say well why is one
tribe doing it because it's a cultural
thing right all the evidence indicates
that this is a cultural thing right that
yeah some muslims do some animists are
doing it people who are like you know
have other type of religions christians
are doing it as well coptic christians
in egypt are doing it as well right so
this is an african issue primarily a few
other countries like yemen indonesia
because uh you know it has to do with
demographics of how people moved into
different regions and traveled this is
not an islamic thing this is not an
islamic problem it's not an islamic
issue did the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him did he have it done to his
daughters no were his own wives had this
procedure done no there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever so what it looks
like is that basically you know what
probably happened is that this was a
cultural practice
and the muslims in that area were
probably trying to use their religion to
justify that practice even though it's
not a very strong justification the
christians did exactly the same thing
they were had this practice as well and
they tried to justify it and what's
really interesting is when christian
missionaries arrived in africa and
people were ex you know entering into
christianity the christian church many
of these christian missionaries they
said you guys got to stop this practice
you got to stop doing it and they
wouldn't stop so they said okay we're
going to kick you out we're going to
excommunicate you from our churches you
can't even be a christian anymore if you
continue this practice and they
continued it anyways and they said okay
fine so many people are kicked out of
the church which means that
this is a tribal thing are muslims in
pakistan doing this no are muslims in
saudi arabia or muslims in syria or
muslims in lebanon muslim and palestine
muslims all across the world like i said
there's 49 majority muslim countries
one-third of the muslim population lives
in other places as minorities
most the vast majority of muslims are
not doing it you don't have any solid
evidence linking this to you know it to
being a practice in islam yet it keeps
on being tied somehow with the religion
of islam
and i don't understand why why this
keeps happening
looks like people whatever they can get
their hands on
either out of context to twist it to
cherry pick um
any stone they can get to throw that's
it uh it's
it just goes back to being disingenuous
and misinformed and a victim many people
to that uh false propaganda that's out
there but but joe our friend joe talks
about
um he talks about being professionally
objective supposed to be professionally
objective professionally wise
being wise right yeah one of those
things is you know to do what we're
suggesting that he does
is why not have
bring on your friend
bring on someone like you and let's go
let's talk let's have a that'd be a
great i think that would that would
really bring out a lot of lot of
viewership huh absolutely a lot of
people being tuned like now he's got his
his uh buddy who's making these claims
you know what i mean right and now we
got someone who's gonna fact check it
right there and say right
yeah you have to go back to the internet
on the spot searching around right yeah
yeah all right uh let's go to um to
another one about the muslims
uh being the ones responsible for the
most suicide attacks yeah how about the
one that is responsible for most of the
suicide bombing oh that's islamophobic i
am islamophobic yeah so this idea of you
know suicide bombings and suicide
killings and all that it's important
again to understand this in context and
understand you know where did this start
what is the history behind it and why do
people do it and where's the connection
between islam there's always this
somehow this connection between islam
and suicide bombing that's what's in the
minds of many people because that's what
they consume in mainstream media
unfortunately let's let's take a look at
some facts okay the first recorded
suicide attack that we know of as as
human beings as researchers was actually
done by christian crusaders
against muslims
so there was a group of crusaders who
actually sunk their own ship so they
could that they could actually result in
10 times the deaths of muslims
uh on that you know for the expedition
right so this is the first incident
right this is classical then you fast
forward to like the modern era you find
the first suicide bombing modern suicide
bombing that's taking place in saint
petersburg right in 18 let's see what's
the year i got um
where they killed the czar basically
the guy was not a muslim this was not a
muslim suicide bombing and suicide
bombings continued it continues and it
continues with kamikazes so in war you
got the japanese and what they're doing
is many japanese are volunteering
themselves to get in airplanes and they
go and they crash you know bombs into
certain you know ships and to sing those
ships the germans are practicing the
same type of suicide bombing techniques
during the battle uh for berlin against
the russians so they're going and
they're trying to destroy the bridges
that are coming they're sacrificing
their own lives for a military purpose
and then what really happened is there
really wasn't much suicide bombing
during the cold war period that's really
interesting the reason why there and
this is important for everyone to
understand specifically joe is that the
reason why there wasn't suicide bombing
during the cold war period is because
the superpowers of the us and russia
soviet union they're equipping these
little countries that are fighting with
each other right they're equipping them
with a lot of weapons when you have a
lot of weapons to fight other people
back with you don't need suicide bombing
so then what happened was is that we
don't see much during the cold war the
next instance of suicide bombing that we
start seeing is in lebanon so in lebanon
when israel goes and occupies lebanon in
the early 80s
you get a movement of people who cannot
fight back against superior military
technology that israel has so they start
getting this idea of let's go start
doing the suicide bombings what's really
interesting and this is how suicide
bombing became prevalent in modern
society today it started in lebanon
particularly and what's really
interesting is 77 percent of the people
who are engaging in suicide bombings in
lebanon they were communists or
socialists they were not doing it for
islamic reasons they were not doing it
because you know they're inspired to do
for some muslim cause or something like
that and what's more interesting is
eight percent of them were christian as
well
right so this is not a religious thing
this is a secular thing meaning in the
sense that it's something that people
are doing because they have no other
military option to carry out anything
and then when people saw that israel
actually backed out of lebanon they say
oh well it looks like suicide bombing's
potentially working
and we don't have any resources to fight
back we should do something along these
lines right so now somehow you know
what's going on in the world today is
whenever you find a group of people it
doesn't matter if it's the tamil tigers
in sri lanka who are not religious this
is not a muslim group they have nothing
to do with islam at all they were
conducting suicide bombings
against the government so that they
could get their own tamil region right
why are they doing this this is a way
for people who don't have many resources
to fight back for whatever cause they're
fighting for so when you're deciding
who's a terrorist and what's a terrorist
and who's fighting and who's suicide
bombing the first thing you've got to
ask yourself is
is this cause justified what they're
fighting for are they freedom fighters
are they terrorists the second the
second thing is do they have the ability
to fight or they don't have the ability
to fight back if they don't have any
weapons and they're being oppressed or
they have no resources whatsoever then
yeah they might be willing to utilize
their bodies what does all of this have
to do with islam
absolutely nothing
there is absolutely nothing connected
with the religion of islam that's saying
you should go and use yourself as a vic
you know use your body as a a way of
going and you know targeting a specific
bomb at an individual or going and you
know killing innocent civilians or all
the other things that are somehow
connected or tied to suicide bombing
so this idea of islam is responsible for
suicide bombing it's just another
another one of those you know just fake
misleading propaganda statements that
just keeps being thrown out there and it
kind of takes away the context of what
is the political circumstance going on
in that specific area in that country
where we need to analyze
is this struggle just or unjust
killing of innocent civilians is never
just it's never allowed in islam but
that's not even when people say suicide
bomb they're not even talking about that
they have a problem with this idea of
suicide and bombing and killing or
whatever it is this is a military thing
it's a political thing in order for this
to take place there needs to be
political context that's what needs to
be kept in mind and who i see who
substantiate academics they don't bring
them on mainstream media because it
doesn't support the narrative no and it
would educate the public
to
you know the the awareness of really
what's going on in these are in these
areas of the world that robert pape you
know the terrorist expert he analyzed
over a thousand
different terrorist attacks to date and
he talks about hey this has little to
nothing to do with islam or
religion a lot of times he said that
many of these are secularists he says
and people are about to do a suicide
attack and now they're going to face
death and all of a sudden they become
religious right right because that's it
now people find god at the end right and
now they cling on to it but in reality
it's because they want the occupying
force out of there and like you're
saying they have no other means right
and again
anything to do with islam now no no it's
it's all political it's political it's
it's political that's exactly what the
terrorist expert dr robert
that's what university congress says
every terrorist expert says that you
know what there's a political you know
objective that's there you need to
justify that objective you're gonna
you're gonna justify it either with
nationalism
nazi party neo-nazi whatever it is
you're gonna justify it with some
religion that you practice you're going
to justify it with your superiority of
your race you need to justify the
political objective some people will use
religion to justify it some people will
use nationalism some people will use
race they'll use other you know factors
if there's no political objective then
there's not going to be any terrorism
in my opinion it's injustice humiliation
oppression that is are the most common
causes of terrorism
some people claim that religion
motivates terrorists however the
academic research of dr robert pape has
proved the claim to be false
uh what i did is i collected the first
complete database of every suicide
terrorist attack around the world since
1980 the first version of this database
uh
was uh
published a few years ago and it went
from 1980 to 2003.
i think of that as like the pre-iraq
database and then the second version
from 2004
on think of that as the data that's
happened since iraq
and what the data shows quite clearly is
that
the principal cause of suicide terrorism
is foreign occupation in that period
from 1980 to 2003 there were 315
completed suicide terrorist attacks by
suicide terrorists who actually killed
themselves i don't mean attempts these
are people who actually killed
themselves
the world leader during that 24-year
period was not an islamic group at all
they are the tamil tigers in sri lanka
the tamil tigers are a marxist group a
secular group a hindu group
in fact over half of those 462 suicide
attackers were purely secular because
you see many muslim suicide terrorist
groups are also
purely secular such as the pkk in turkey
the pkk in turkey which did numerous
suicide attacks in the 1990s
is again a marxist read anti-religious
suicide terrorist group because you see
if islam as sort of a radical religion
or if it were just radical muslims
doing this then what you would expect is
sort of this thin veneer of suicide
attack kind of scattered all around the
world you would expect that oh there's
1.4 billion muslims you know there's
this teeny tiny fringe of muslims kind
of everywhere who'd be willing to do
suicide attack uh but that's not the way
the data looks it's really concentrated
and it's really concentrated in
occupations yeah so i wonder like people
like joe or whoever you know to get
criminals out or get people who've taken
over his backyard maybe he got a few
acres right and they're bringing harm
upon his family killing somebody he's
got a big family you know what what
would again islam doesn't justify
killing innocent men women and children
is clear but what would many of these
people end up doing to you can imagine
we have guidelines there's guidelines in
islam right that keeps us in check
yeah imagine if people don't have any
guidelines which they don't imagine what
they what what the people doing absolute
chaos yeah yeah we we uh we got a few
more we're going to take a break um
uh and we'll be back uh to keep
addressing some of these
um
some of the myths much of the
misinformation is too much to cover but
we're just giving a few of them here on
the show and hopefully our good friend
we can have him on the program he can
come he's even on the show or we can
reach out and have our friend shay
mustapha from the college of california
california islamic university yeah we'll
be right back don't go anywhere we got
uh
some some more exciting things to cover
be right back peace
welcome back to the dean show and this
is our
sincere
genuine attempt to reach out to people
such as joe rogan
has a massive following one of the
probably number one podcasts out there
in the world
and
people who have been on this program
fans of his kind of get them acquainted
with the muslims and some of the false
propaganda and
and and the genuine people would be like
people don't like being lied to
absolutely yeah
so when you're when you're lied to you
like what else have i been lied to right
yeah and there's a lot of things out
there misinformation and it's just sad
to say i mean um
joe like many have fallen victim to the
islamophobia machine imagine if if a
quarter million dollars plus is being
spent
on bashing islam
creating mistruths and misinformation
you're going to get affected by it
that's uh that's right yeah let's
continue going on to to another one
he talks about uh
stoning of
homosexuals how many of you believe that
the word of god is the best way to deal
with homosexuals and that what whatever
the quran says whether it says they
should be stoned to death yeah he
mentioned
the quran says to stone homosexuals
i mean i would just say to joe i would i
would love to see that verse
because uh i've studied the quran for
over 15 years
6236 verses never came across that once
i don't know which quran he's looking at
i'm not sure which one he's going to but
i would love to see where that where it
says that because i i missed it and i
think every other muslim in the entire
world missed it
you know yeah so there's there's no
stoning of the cur of uh in the quran of
homosexuals no the only time it talks
about homosexuality in the quran is in
the story of prophet lot
it doesn't talk about any other rules
with regards to homosexuals in the quran
so i'm not sure where exactly he's
getting that
let's go into women being silent not
being allowed to talk and like he goes
into this thing about how many of you
think that women should be silent and
that they should you know should listen
to their man because this is what god
has said they all raise their hand and
he's like see this is this is not
radical islam this is just islam so all
these people that say oh they're so
radical they're radical islam and that
he doesn't even realize that he's
demonstrating radical islam so he yeah
he said again he said the quran says
that women are not allowed to talk in
front of men they have to be silent
um so again i i don't know where he got
this from the quran
there's something similar to that in the
bible okay let's see what happens when
we read some verses from the bible to
people here at west islam has been under
constant scrutiny and muslims are being
accused of following religion that has
no place in our western culture
we would like to read a few random
passages from the quran and see if you
agree if you have hear my lulls
and reject my commands you will have to
eat the flesh of your own dollars and
your own sons do not allow for a woman
to teach if two men sleep together you
will have to kill them
see this is actually not holy cram this
is actually
a holy bible
if she does you'll have to cut off her
hand and do not forgive her that's the
holy one right why would that be in the
holy bible does this surprise you yes
100 because you would never think
terrible stuff like that would be in the
holy bible
that that's ridiculous there's there's
no way that's the bible i i've read the
bible there's that stuff i'm not in
there no if you were a muslim reading
the white bible do you think christians
would be radical
yes 100 yeah but definitely not in the
quran
um so maybe he mis mistake mistook the
two books i'm not sure exactly what
happened there but this idea of you know
women being silent or them not being
allowed to talk this is just destroying
it seems like he's throwing out a bunch
of random stuff i mean there's there's a
surah a chapter in the quran it's called
mujadillah it's about a woman who came
and complained to the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him about her husband
and
god
allah puts this in the quran the story
like praising the woman that she had the
courage to go and complain and that her
husband was wrong what he was doing was
wrong and she was right so like if it's
if it's telling them to be silent why is
why is the quran showing the story and
saying hey here you go you can check it
out it's called surah mujahid the one
who complained or the woman who
complained
it's it's near the end of the quran
there's an entire chapter on that and
there's nothing like this i'm not i
don't know where this stuff is coming
from or what sources they're coming from
i think the fact checking really needs
uh some work there and maybe maybe this
is in the show there's is there another
guy in the back yeah like double
checking the facts but you know what
maybe that guy you know needs to he
needs to hook up with again with a
qualified islamic scholar
exactly and they get you on the phone
say hey look right now we're doing this
but what do you think
and i'm ready for that yeah that's the
problem with google you know i mean the
thing is google is great service but you
just throw in some things there's
something called seo seo i'm a computer
science major as well so it's called
search engine optimization so if you use
the right tags and use the right thing
and use enough you pay the right people
they can get your results up in the
search engine so you're trying to search
something all the false articles with
the propaganda and the misleading
statements and all of that they will be
at the top and that's what you said this
islamophobia industries over 200 million
dollars is being invested in all of this
stuff a lot of it is search engine
optimization so when you're trying to do
your own research you're going to get
all these results coming in the
beginning and you got to like get
through it you need to go to google
scholar instead of just google yeah
right there's a there's academic
research you need to go and check with
muslim scholars you need to look at
their scholarly research papers to
actually find this stuff and what's
really going on you kind of have to you
know sift through it a little bit if
you've been kind of programmed that one
along with the
quote i mentioned from time magazine
that's also the 60 000 plus books over a
span of 100 years yeah it's probably not
those same arguments that are the false
arguments the no the misconception
they're all put on the internet also i'm
sure yeah yeah uh but don't we have is
that a a situation where you also had
now from one one of um the predecessors
of the prophet muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him
where a woman he was he was um he was
stating something and a woman got up he
was giving a sermon yeah yep she got up
they didn't like she got up
shut your mouth in the middle of the
sermon yeah right but you're not even
supposed to no one's supposed to talk in
the middle of the sermon but she was
correcting him on something so i she got
up and she's like i gotta correct you
she fact-checked him she fact-checked
him yeah and he's the leader of
we're talking the muslim world at the
time which is stretching you know
throughout the persian empire roman
empire i mean this was a major thing
it's a political leader you try this on
some other people and you know you see
what happens to you let alone being a
woman you know so we have that history
but she was fact-checking based on
evidence that's right yeah just you know
and he admitted it and that's the
beautiful thing you know that's the
beautiful thing about umar he admitted
it he didn't say i'm not going to take
this advice from a woman or she
interrupt me during interrupted me
during my sermon he realized that what
she was saying was correct and he said
my you know she she quoted a verse of
the quran that he didn't really reflect
upon at the time and and she's like you
know he's like you know you're
absolutely right i i forgot you know the
woman is right and i'm wrong and he
declared it publicly yeah and that's the
beauty of you know that humility when
you realize you're wrong about something
you realize you said something you know
incorrect you're willing to make that
adjustment you know it doesn't matter
who's correcting me if i value the truth
i'm gonna you know be willing to accept
that i made a mistake
and that's interesting because you do
have and again uh our our friends out
there from the christians and jews and i
never want to intentions never to to
put down anyone's religion or anything
but you do have
uh an aspect of of
a community there
that are deliberately trying to confuse
people spread this false information and
some of his guests
that have been on there so why and i
think a part of it was
inbreeding
uh this is your own theory no no look at
someone else's breeding major
major problems never heard this because
especially with immigrants in britain
like the pakistanis in london they're
they're part of a media program and they
constantly have
um attacks on islam
greetings infidel
i work with care i want sharia law in
this country
women are second-class citizens
i hate white males am i liberals
or am i islam
and his friend who's actually a catholic
christian it's all the same now
and others
um he was on his show
this would apply these verses would
apply if you're because this is part of
the new testament about being quiet not
speaking in public not teaching in
public covering your hair all of these
things so it's like you're attacking
muslims but these these people
it's in your own book these would be
christians who are who are totally
islamophobic this not everyone you have
so many christians who are out there who
are you know guarding muslims from
praying absolutely you know we have
great alliances you know with some great
people out there but these people i
think who have more in common with such
radical fringe elements is like it's
like they're the new version the upgrade
of the kkk exactly right they have more
in common with they actually agree more
with isis that's right you know that's
right they're very similar so now they
don't see what their own book is saying
yeah and we can play this all day now
and night and we can start throwing
these verses explain this one yeah
explain that one and that's the
hypocrisy of it you know hypocrisy even
if we had those verses which we don't
but if we had those verses then you have
the same verses so if you say well you
know well ours aren't taken literally
because that's normally the answer we
don't take that literally so why you
should take ours literally then right
but but it's not the case but that's
where the hypocrisy comes in and that's
a problem people should understand where
they themselves are coming from before
and you clean yourself up before you
start criticizing you know other people
yeah let's move along so we covered that
one
this guy i just don't know it's just
it's just mind-blowing uh his guest
joel's guest who he has on the joe rogan
podcast
i don't who is this guy he he starts
talking about you know about uh
muslims treatment towards jews
right and
there i've i've we've had
programs on this in the past
well let me just cover this clip first
uh what is the position on uh islam
regarding jews okay well i mean we
escape
lebanon because we're going to be
executed okay
by it wasn't by the amish okay right uh
so i said you know what rather than kind
of go into a whole treatise here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to share with
you a montage of imams from around the
world so this is not culture specific
there's indonesian imam a malaysian
kuwaiti yemeni
so these are at their sermons this is at
the mosque where they are preaching what
should be done to the jews
and one of the particular
imams was showing images of the nazis
bulldozing uh skeletons into the ditches
and he was lamenting to god why god
wouldn't didn't you give us the pleasure
of exterminating those jewish rats why
do you hate us so much jewish rats of
some version of that right so he picks
some random you see what he's saying
that uh some imam somebody what do you
what do you say to that yeah i mean this
is what you do is
you cherry pick some random quote
unquote imam making some statements
somewhere and says look look there's a a
muslim somewhere who has some type of
following 10 people 100 people we don't
even know and look he said something
wrong
yeah there's like people like that
around the entire world who say really
ridiculous things
the former chief shafari rabbi of israel
has just proclaimed that the only reason
that you as a non-jew exists on earth
is to serve
jews
another jewish religious leader says
it's moral for a jew to murder you and
steal your heart or liver if a jew needs
one
now maybe you think i'm making all this
up
but i tell you jewish extremist evil is
too crazy for anybody to make it up
now you probably haven't heard the
rabbi's words yet he's not on fox news
cnn doesn't cover it but it has been
covered extensively in israel just not
america
of course rabbi yosef is right most
gentiles do serve the jews we fight
their wars in iraq and afghanistan spill
the blood of tens of thousands of our
young men and suffer
terrible
injuries and death to those nations
we spend the treasure of trillions of
dollars in these wars for israel believe
that
there is an honor in you that will not
allow you to be a slave to anyone much
less to such an evil power
as
zionism even some courageous jews are
joining the fight against jewish
extremism and i salute them that's right
in all religions and in non-religions as
well you know so this is the problem is
that you know you go and cherry-pick
something you say oh well that's you
know that somehow represents what all
1.7 billion muslims are saying that's
that's again very disingenuous that's
the problem is that you're not being
honest with people and you're misleading
them to think that all muslims believe
this thing because one person said it
okay what is their basis for saying it
is there any basis in the religion our
religion is based upon the quran and the
teachings of the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him did he exhibit those things
or did it contradict what he's teaching
none of that stuff is there you know so
when it came to the idea of
you know
this how muslims treat jews or how islam
is supposed to be dealing with with
jewish people and all of that this idea
is is is ridiculous you know that um
muslims have been living with jews in
many parts of the world specifically in
spain
uh you know in the past when you know
muslims are actually in control of spain
for like 800 years muslims and jews were
living there peacefully there was no
major issues muslims and jews were
living peacefully in the ottoman empire
in fact when the jews were kicked out of
europe most of them were going to the
ottoman empire and they said that you
know they were uh they were flourishing
at that time in spain it was their
golden age so relations between muslims
and jews outside of you know
some hostile political context has
always been generally fine and that's
still the case generally outside of any
political context where's this idea of
hatred from jews and because of some
imam quoted something right we can go
and we can start showing clips of
christian preachers chabad calls
non-jewish women shiksas shiksa
literally means [__] and it calls
gentile girls shikselba or little [__]
now can you imagine the outrage of
gentiles or any christians called jewish
girls little jewish [__]
but they do this all the time in the
media in fact oh sure they're jewish and
you're a shakespeare what
means non-jewish women
from catholics from protestants we could
show jewish rabbis saying some something
every gentile member of congress voted
to honor this freak who says that every
gentile and every gentile congressman
is totally evil and every one of their
wives and mother's daughters is a [__]
now that's true slavery when you vote to
honor somebody who says your mother is a
[__] and who tells you that your sole
purpose on earth is to serve we superior
jews we can go and show atheists we can
go and show agnostics we can go and show
ufc fighters right which joe was you
know mma we can show a bunch of mma
people making ridiculous statements are
you going to go and say look this
represents all mma fighters
[Applause]
go go buy for you god
go for jesus
no forget jesus people
no
joe wouldn't think that no one else
would think that so you don't do that
you don't go pick a few bad people make
their statements and then say well see
the legs represents everyone you know so
now your audience is is is getting a
picture portrayed to them like muslims
hate jews yes islam teaches hatred of
you know jews and now uh that incites
like these guys and now you're hearing
acid in the face you're hearing female
genitalia
female genital mutilation honor ki
man i had a guest the other day he said
i watched fox news i got my phd thesis
in in um in in and what was it uh in one
area i forgot what it was and he said
you know
it was making my blood pressure go up
listening to and i know the facts so
imagine someone is listening to all this
people are generally good people and
they're you're dehuman dehumanizing them
and you don't have the facts but when
you fax check you know if you look at
it's one thing us saying this but when
you have in the
in the jewish chronicles when you have
professor academics historians like uh
this professor jewish professor david
warrenstein he wrote the jc essay and he
says islam saved jewry the jew the
jewish people there's a great a rabbi
out there
um rabbi singer
and he talks about the jews had it
better than in any other place
no better place than they were when in
the muslim lands yeah and i've started
all my life the rabbinical school from
abc i come from the most traditional
what's called black hat
world okay my father is a great teacher
rosh yeshiva i don't i come from the
traditional world we all have our nut
jobs all the crazy we have crazy jews
wackos and we have crazy christians and
we have crazily muslim we all have our
nut jobs welcome to the
welcome welcome to the show
and they're good people they're so sweet
i mean i'm telling the people i interact
with i'm not saying the head of isis is
sweet they're maniacs isis went and came
here to jakarta to kill muslims i mean
they're
eat wicked what they're doing and they
abuse these texts in the quran and
hadith in order to kill people and rape
women and so on and all muslims i mean
all
majority muslims condemn this but
so i'm talking about people who are
serious who really care about god who
care about the truth who recognizes the
problem i'm talking to you everyone else
you don't listen to the show shut her up
and go somewhere else i don't mean that
disrespectfully but if you can't
separate the two then you're going to be
in la la land but if i read other news
i'll think that all muslims are a bunch
of baby killers so and drive planes into
buildings forget that garbage okay
that's nonsense let's talk facts now and
this is why jews got along with muslims
beautiful now with christians
my family was wiped out by the by the
hallow
in the holocaust
wiped out
almost i mean just by luck my great
grandfather came to america went back
and then and my grandfather grandmother
came when they were able to come but
their everybody was wiped out in my
field i think 42 members of my family
were wiped out by the nazis may they
perish in hell but those were all
christians they were they weren't and
don't tell me the nazis weren't
christians believe me they had a belt
buckle on the waffen says got me turns
and if you whatever i don't want to get
into that point but it did not happen in
islamic countries okay the holocaust did
not happen in islamic countries it
happened in europe europe either
directly europeans directly or passively
murdered the jews
wiped out all of european jewelry
one-third of the jews were dis was wiped
out between 1942 and 1945 but jews were
safe in the eyebrow now with the whole
thing in the middle east
yes there's problems now but
what do you want to do you want to go
throw gasoline on the fire and when when
the koran is critical of jews
they're critical of jews believe me
if you read ezekiel and the criticism of
ezekiel to jews who weren't keeping tyra
the criticism found the quran
doesn't
touch ezekiel 23 or 16. it doesn't come
close it's much the jewish bible is much
more critical of the jews any muslim who
really sincerely studies judaism really
studies it not propaganda on some dumb
website you know what i'm talking about
because on the same dumb websites you
have the crazy website say that muslims
are a bunch of suicide bombers that kill
people and i'm nothing really do these
filthy dogs say this so i'm not talking
about the crazies but the serious
serious people one of the things that
both jews who study islam or muslims
which study judaism go whoa
where
we are
the i mean it's
shocking
how similar we are not exactly the same
let's get that clear in the old days
before you know the state of israel and
so on
there were crazies who persecuted jews
but frankly there is a reason
why jews in the islamic world whether it
was in yemen or in morocco did fabulous
we did better than the muslims did the
muslims were killing each other and the
jews were
doing great now were there exceptions
yes how did we get along so well
my friends there is a reason why jews
and muslims got along better in yemen
got along better in morocco got along
better in egypt got along better in iraq
than muslims and muslims than when they
were unfortunately killing each other
over
what
over primarily politics
you know albania how many did
after the holocaust you know how many
jews were taken in by the ottomans by
the by the by the albanians you know by
the muslims you also have my good friend
miko pillad who's a strong advocate you
know for the because all this stems
really uh for the the theft of the the
uh the palestinians land
right this comes from that but before
it's modern conflict but you have jews
my friends my jewish friends rabbi weiss
you know who's been on the show
foreign
oh my god israeli friend mikko pilot
he's been on the show when you take away
people's land and you destroy their
homes
when you incarcerate their fathers and
quite often their mothers uh when you
shoot their brothers and sisters in the
in their school in the schoolyards
this is what we get this is the price
that you pay as as as a society that
maintains such a brutal oppression and
occupation against another people
there's a price to be paid and this is
the price that we pay and therefore they
both felt
that
they both held the israeli government
responsible because the israeli
government is responsible for the
reality that exists there now someone
just said that's an anti-semitic
statement you just made somebody's
pointing the finger and say this guy's
anti-semitic what do you have to say
about that
well i'm jewish so being anti-semitic is
nonsense number one number two being
anti-semitic means being racist against
jews i'm not raised against jews
um but i am critical of the state of
israel i'm critical of zionism which has
really nothing to do with jews
although they claim to so there's
nothing anti-semitic about criticizing
israel a fact most jews don't even live
there
most jews never accepted zionism so i
don't think there's
that has anything to do with it it's a
claim that's being thrown out when
there's nothing else to say when the
other side the pro-israeli side
the side that supports the violence in
palestine
has nothing to say they say anti-semitic
well so they say anti-semitic what if
someone says look he's just a
self-hating jew have you heard this
statement
yeah well i certainly don't hate myself
that's nonsense
and i don't hate anybody else i think
it's again it's one of those things they
throw at you when they're when they've
got no argument
and these people they love muslims they
get along
they tell the facts a totally different
story an academic story
but what is this story yeah this story
that these guys he's picked some some
some rotten plum out here yeah
exactly yeah unfortunately what is it is
that january
absolutely that's that's that's uh
that's why it's important to have a
variety of guests yeah and have a
variety of opinions that's the only way
to arrive at the truth yeah uh let's
let's move on so he talks about
women now women
and women being forced
to cover that's true but if it's some
imam who thinks that you know women
should cover themselves up like they
look like jabba the hutt or what is it
was it boba fett whichever one
whatever it is please direct your hate
mail to joe rogan come it bring it on
and he has a problem with that yeah you
know the language that he uses the
language that's the thing the language
that's that's the thing i mean he says
he's making fun of muslim women who are
choosing to cover their hair because one
it's a religious requirement and two
they're doing it out of modesty they're
not the first people in the past or even
today who cover out of modesty women
women
wear hijab when they go outside of the
house i mean who are not even muslim can
you equate that absolutely yeah i mean
everyone walking around naked yeah
exactly they're covering themselves
there's a type of modesty that's there
right but he's going and saying you know
they're dressed like jabba the hutt you
know i didn't really get that example
then he corrected and said oh they're
dressed like boba fett
not really cool not really it's not it's
not it's not cool you know so and
especially not in the current climate
yeah where you know you got france
just passed a law that forbade muslim
women from wearing their quote-unquote
burkini which is like you know their
hijab
that they're going to go and swim and
the beach with it's forbidden they're
not allowed to even practice that you
want to talk about freedom of religion
or freedom you know to criticize all
that freedom that we keep hearing about
they can't even go to the beach they're
not you're not allowed to dress how you
want to dress right and then to make fun
of them and use some star wars figures
and all of that stuff it's it's not cool
at all bullying is an epidemic now yeah
it's it's a major epidemic and
specifically muslim women who are being
bullied i mean their bullying's not cool
it's happened to many of my friends i
know personally my wife's friends they
go out in the supermarket people not
only give them stares they actually like
shout insults at them you know why are
you wearing that rag over your head why
are you doing this they don't even feel
comfortable going to the grocery store
and this is not some exaggerated feeling
this is fact based right muslim women
have had their hijab ripped off from
them and this is not isolated incident
this is happening on a major you know
significant level so just throw it off
and say you know what well we have the
freedom to criticize your religion but
you don't have the freedom to dress how
you want to dress you have to adopt our
understanding our principles of what
modesty or of what what freedom of dress
should be like right that's exactly the
type of narrow-mindedness that he's
criticizing in all these other aspects
so you got to be consistent yeah you
have to be consistent in what you're
saying there was a jewish another jewish
academic and this is interesting this is
what he said dr norman fickelstein he
said when europeans came to north
america the thing they said about the
native americans is that they were so
barbaric because they walked around
naked the european women at that time
they were wearing three layers of
clothes then they came to north america
and decided that the native americans
were backward because they were all
rocked around naked
and he continues and he says and now we
walk around naked and we say that the
muslims are backward because they wear
so so much so much clothes can you
imagine anything more barbaric banning
women from wearing head scarves so this
is a jewish man yeah right absolutely
who's got you know who who's has uh
friends with muslims we're friends with
him i mean these are people working
together to some obvious facts what do
you think about that so he's talking
about when they came over right they
were way pretty much hijab yep if you
look at the eighties exactly exactly
yeah and they were walking around naked
now they're trying to exactly that
that's really the problem the crux of
this problem is this holier-than-thou
attitude yeah right it's like you know
looking at them these are less you know
less people than us they're lesser than
us they're uncivilized they're backwards
in one of his you know things he said uh
him or one of his guests said islam is
500 years behind what is that supposed
to mean like this idea of well we've
changed our cultural norms we started
dressing a different way we've even
changed our morals
and now you guys are behind now you know
you should be following exactly what we
what we're doing we set the trends and
if you don't follow the trend then
you're backwards you're behind you need
to catch up
this this idea this is like that
orientalism idea that you know edward
saeed was mentioning in his book
kind of deconstructing this idea of
people who are in a position to go and
like classify others into a certain
frame thinking that you need to be like
us we you're uncivilized we're civilized
we need to come and civilize you
there needs to be a little bit more
nuance than that we're trying to
understand people and joe's a bright guy
i mean he mentions when he starts to
think objectively like he says
professionally wisely and he sees like
and he mentions this about why why would
people be doing some of the things right
um and he talks about their natural
resources being stolen
he talks about dehumanization
and and and and
that's what really gave me hope you know
when i saw when i saw him talking about
that in this clip to the suppression of
the people that live in these places
where their natural resources are being
stolen in by the war machine right which
is undeniable undeniable what's going on
in iraq or in afghanistan
how much of it how much of the hustle
has to do with the natural resources
whether it be the poppy fields whether
they be the minerals in afghanistan
whether it's the oil in iraq undeniable
that these people are being sure
for sure they're subject to the war
machine that's coming in to steal the
resources right and that that's
that's something that
people are aware of and you see these
images of these people in these islamic
countries that are dying that are
getting bombed on and and also the
dehumanism that they're subjected to by
a lot of people that are trying to
justify this these wars that that is the
only thing that makes sense to me he's
like yeah okay i i understand muslims
across the world their resources are
being taken from them they're being
oppressed they're being dehumanized he
says we're not going to deny what's
happening in iraq what's happening in
afghanistan it's horrible what's
happening and then he kind of hints at
the answer
that he's almost there he almost figures
out why islamophobia is a problem why we
shouldn't be you know doing all this
disrespect and all that
but then right when he's there and he's
saying you know that could play a role
then his guest
you know somehow diverts him and takes
him off on some other tangent and then
that thought is just gone so i think i
think joe is is searching and i think
he's trying to find out but he's just
it's like someone who has a problem an
addiction or whatever they're trying to
get rid of but all the friends around
them they keep reinforcing that behavior
and even though they're trying to get
out until they kind of clear the way
from those friends and try and associate
with other people spend a little bit
time with others
they're not going to be able to get out
because they're always being sucked back
into that bad habit that they have when
you blow a people back into you know
time i mean you put you
you like he said joe says you know you
steal their resources
you do all sorts of injustices towards
them and now you're criticized these
countries afghanistan
you have um iraq that just been blown to
smithereens how do you and then puppets
been put you know they've been colonized
you know puppets been put as to to run
those countries uh what i mean how how f
far forward do you expect them to be
when you you've like blown everything up
that's true what do you want
you know yep yeah yeah that is it it's
uh and then and then at the end to try
to blame islam when you burn all i mean
if you've blown up their libraries yeah
you took the libraries
stole the artifacts you know you know
crazy stuff going on yeah
keeping people saying that there is
islam it's kicking people that's what
led to the destabilization of the entire
region i mean it's it's much worse than
it was before you know so complaining
with you know the false pretext of
supposed biological weapons and all that
that all turned out to be false i mean
that's the importance of fact-checking
again right if if someone would have if
if some people would have done their
proper fact checking
all these people would not have been
killed in iraq they should not have been
killed in the first place because the
whole pretext of invading iraq was about
these chemical biological weapons that
never existed and in fact our data was
not even accurate on that it was just a
it was a lie it was it was a lie so it
was built it was the premise was built
on what we know today was like and i'm
sure i'm sure joe and most people would
accept it this is very clearly now come
out to the public that this was a lie
and this pretext was completely made up
it's completely fake based on flimsy
information and then you have
conservative numbers what do they put it
at you have uh physicians for what what
is physicians for social responsibility
something like that where they talk
about almost in the span of 10 years
like almost 2 million
innocent lives were lost on a war that
was built based on a lie it's not online
yeah there was a have you seen a it's a
great documentary by really respected
investigative journalists it's called
dirty wars yes have you seen it yes i
have seen that yeah people need to see
that they need to see that absolutely
you know they show did you see the part
the guy is just sitting and he he worked
as a translator for the
for the army for the americans and then
and then what happens uh in one part of
the documentary dirty wars they're just
hanging out the guy just got married now
put people they have to put themselves
in the situation the guy just got
married and they heard some you know
helicopters whatever and then he goes
outside and i don't him his son and how
many other people just killed they were
just enjoying themselves yeah they're
just dead yeah so these people have been
dehumanized that's the thing we don't we
don't we don't hear their stories
they're not seen as people they're just
seen as a just a target and okay they're
just numbers yeah 1 million 2 million
half a million it's just a number for
most people unfortunately and all based
on and joe's a objective person and he
many of these events that have happened
such as nine 911 and whatnot he's had
people like
the
uh
people who want a new investigation on a
911.
and he's someone who doesn't just
swallow this stuff whole you know
believing it his guest
talks about these guys who did 9 11.
so now unquestionably one of the hardest
things yeah so so you just gotta just
like a detective you gotta look at it
like a detective you got you got okay
that building came down so
we the people want to know uh what
happened at tower seven how come it
looks like a demo it looks like it
exploded it looks look it must be
exploded that's the conspiracy theory
what does the government say nothing
it's not in the 911 commission report
they deny it there's no there's they
don't say anything they don't
acknowledge it after public pressure of
wanting to know if uh that was a
controlled demo or not we want a real
investigation finally in 2008 they found
this finally came out a government
agency comes out and he's and they ask
him they go what he gives a little
presentation that tower 7
was brought down because it got too hot
and then he starts fielding questions
and they said
why didn't you guys test for explosives
this is what this is all about you know
what he said the answer was there were
no witnesses that said they heard
explosions
that was his answer and there's uh
endless endless video someone's gonna
make a meme after video after video
after video fireman policeman witness
after witness after witness at the
butcher
there's on video on video right when it
happens and then the bombs went off and
then before that plane and then bombs
were just and then the whole lobby was
just bombed and then we turned around we
were going down the elevator and the
elevator blew up and this everyone's
saying bombs that the newscasters are
saying while they're there everyone's
saying bombs are going off everywhere
everyone they took all that and buried
it they were saying there's all this
they said miss it's on video they're
saying we didn't have any they go you
didn't check for explosives they go no
we didn't check for explosive there was
no witnesses that said they heard
explosions
now i'm not gonna get into you know the
over two or close to three thousand
architects and engineers you know that
are calling for reinvestigation family
members and whatnot i'm a family member
trying to find out the answers to the
murder of three thousand plus people
please look at architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this took some kind of consciousness
raising on my part before i was willing
to
look at the the possibilities and really
you need to go where the evidence leaves
as an engineer i have three degrees in
engineering i signed that petition for
architects and engineers for 9 11 truth
some time ago because the american
people absolutely need the truth of 9
11.
look at the evidence in fact i'll say
this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought forward has
got to come away with the feeling that
something has to be done a real
investigation has to be put forward but
now the example that i want i want to
strike is if again oneness in life is
tragic enough that's just horrible islam
condemns it it doesn't condone it but
now imagine like if if
that
we've been off of that
how many people have died because of
that in another part of the world right
so that cycle that hate now that
violence terrorism cycle so now the
feelings that you feel never forget
now you're bombing droning all these
people people they don't put themselves
in other people's shoes
not justifying not at all killing
innocent men when children but what are
these people feeling they're human
beings too how it's like these people
are just less human what what are you
have you talked with people what do you
ask them like are you uh do you innocent
life there blood here same blood the
same i mean yeah i mean everyone claims
that yeah all blood is equal but they
don't really treat it unless it's
trending unless it's trendy that that's
the problem we live in like a very
trendy society news is trendy it'll last
one or two weeks and then it doesn't
matter how important it was it's gone
right and and just people's information
people understanding of the world is
extremely restricted
you know and they don't really
understand before when we're about to
invade iraq
people couldn't identify where iraq was
on a map many people probably still
can't do that i mean they don't really
know much about the world yet
we're supposed to be these very highly
educated enlightened intellectuals today
who who are supposed to understand
things the vast majority of people don't
understand things they think they
understand i think there's a lot of
overconfidence in people's
people's own moral compass has a lot of
overconfidence in people's uh view of
what they think they know about the
world and the way the world functions
supposedly in this enlightened time that
we're living in right despite all these
people being you know living misery uh
dying getting killed uh you know just
having the resources stole all of these
things that are happening either people
they don't know about it and they're not
going to take any effort to go and
investigate and it should be presented
to us but it's not right because of
propaganda and war machine and all of
that stuff
or
people know about it
but they're they're distracted you know
what it's really sad i just heard that a
million people got killed in iraq that's
really really bad it bothers me
but you know what let me just go buy a
cup of coffee and let's go watch a movie
we just
numb ourselves and just get rid of it
there's nothing wrong with watching a
movie or buying cup of coffee but to
just forget about that and all of a
sudden we just go and entertain
ourselves
and that's big that's the problem with
with our culture i think is that even
when people do find out
most people when they find out they want
to just remove that because they feel
like they can't do anything about it but
you know what they can do something the
fact that they know about it the fact
that they speak about it in their own
small circle of influence
that's going to influence other people
and eventually public perception public
opinion plays a major role in whether or
not you're going to go and invade a
country or kill a group of people or you
know uh incite hatred against a
particular religious group or religious
minority that makes a difference so even
if you think like you as a small person
you know you only have like 10 friends
20 friends what am i gonna do i can't
save like the entire world yeah you
can't save the world but your
contribution is important and if enough
people do that then you can make a big
difference and people like joe they
don't just have a small circle of
influence they have a huge circle of
influence so when someone like that
does a small part in removing some of
these myths
talking about you know you know we
shouldn't be killing these people and we
shouldn't be staring you know putting a
hatred against them it plays a major
role major role a major role yeah and um
again the experts that we quoted one i'd
like to mention dr uh pape from the
university of chicago again he
clearly states and they don't bring him
on mainstream media because then that
would garner the
the support of more people to be against
you know this hate war cycle but
and and he talks about it's all about
foreign occupation little to nothing to
do with islam
but you have this this force now coming
out you know with all the negative
propaganda you know spewing this false
information so now
oh these people do honor killings oh
these people oppressed women oh these
people basically making them less human
so now people just don't care they think
okay they deserve to be bombed exactly
just bomb them keep bombing smithers
exactly and blame the islam the islam is
the problem right to divert people's
attention from the real problem
over here
exploiting people's resources
you know their land and whatnot what's
really called what's the root problem
causing this right it's not islam right
exactly yeah so hopefully this is our
humble genuine attempt to reach people
like joe rogan
and get you
and others like yourself on his show
that would that would also show
a
a good attempt on his side to be genuine
and not to
you know be balanced well balanced
absolutely i would love to and if he
wants to even meet just privately first
or something like that i'm more than
willing to you know talk to him you're
the imam at a big community in what part
of california in orange county in
anaheim california anaheim california
joe we have
our
good friend here
uh also the dean of academic affairs for
the college of islamic california
california california um university of
islamic studies yes
so we have a person who's qualified who
can help
fact check a lot of these things
anything else we missed i think that's
it we got a lot covered here we covered
quite a bit there's there's a lot more
hopefully in the future we can uh hope
we get a good response
and um
people can help get this push this out
there to mr joe rogan
and
if we get you on the show he get we can
get him on the show if he's ever in
chicago our door is open
and
if he gets you hopefully this has
produced much good and if not um
hopefully the people that watch this
they have a better understanding and the
haters are always just gonna hate it
doesn't matter people just look for a
reason to be angry something to you know
uh take and throw yeah they're not
they're not gonna go away there are
people like that but you know what we
hope to reach out to the people who seem
to be more objective and are willing to
listen yeah that's that's our job and
that's what we want to do
that's it we're out of time i'd like to
thank you thank you for thank you very
much
again and thank you guys thank you joe
if you listen and all the people his
viewers our viewers and tune in to the
dean show every week that's we're here
to sincerely try to deliver clear up the
misconceptions and deliver the true
message of islam and we'll see you next
time until then subscribe if you haven't
already like share
get this out so more people can benefit
see you next time next week same time
same channel until then peace be with
you salaam lake
we encourage people to come to us
and ask